great shot and a great save little pass
behind them that came dangerously close
to too many men snatched away McDavid
makes a move THS home for the
equalizer on a broken play at the Blue
Line McDavid somehow makes it work and
we are
tied
unbelievable I mean he just put on the
Jets and chance after chance and this is
usually what happens when you start to
get these types of sequences beautiful
little pass by for the One Time by Newen
Hopkins denied and then inside the
outside the line just I mean this puck
just sits for McDavid there's nobody
that can put the Jets on like him and
navigate through sticks bodies and what
a deak around the pad I mean he
literally just tucks that around the
right pad of lion who's been so great in
this
game but Conor McDavid ties
it